bonjour à tous merci à tous ceux qui
nous ont rejoints pour ce Facebook live
avec la présidente des républicains donc
le principe vous le connaissez vous avez
posé des disposition nous les avons
retenu et bien je vais les répéter et y
apporter des éléments de réponse alors
la première question nous est posée par
Doumer qui me demande si nous veut te
rions une motion de censure alors voter
une notion de censure ça signifie que
nous acceptions l'idée et que le
gouvernement soit renversé puisque ça
supposerait que les oppositions si
toutes les oppositions se coalisent pour
voter une notion de censure et bien le
gouvernement
tombe et donc on ouvre une crise
institutionnelle
et les républicains ont un sens aigu des
responsabilités ils ne veulent pas le
blocage des institutions contrairement à
la nuque ou au rassemblement national
qui hier ont voté ensemble une motion de
rejet donc on voit bien la coalition de
ces deux groupes d'opposition
donc les républicains sont sur une autre
logique s'opposer proposer oui créer une
crise politique majeure je crois que la
France n'a pas besoin de cela la
deuxième question nous est posée par
Romuald crayez-vous une éventuelle
dissolution de l'Assemblée nationale
alors effectivement ces deux questions
sont liées puisque vous avez noté que le
président Macron a dit si une notion de
censure est votée je dissout
immédiatement
il y avait une forme de menace dans
cette formulation
qui s'adresse sans doute aux oppositions
peut être aussi à sa majorité puisque il
a dit cela l'occasion de la réforme des
retraites et vous savez que sur la
réforme des retraites les premières
critiques sont venues de sa majorité
donc
une dissolution encore faudrait-il que
le Président de la République
la décide encore est-il que toutes les
oppositions votent la motion de censure
et
votez décidé d'une dissolution de
l'Assemblée nationale peut aboutir à un
résultat inverse de celui qui la
prononcé donc c'est quelque chose qui
est périlleuse d'une démarche qui est
périlleuse et qui peut emporter de
nouveaux déséquilibres je crois que la
France encore une fois n'a pas besoin de
cela
Jean-Pierre
c'est une série de questions budgétaires
c'est d'actualité puisque nous allons
bientôt
entamer dans l'hémicycle les premières
discussions sur le budget le projet de
de budget et le projet de loi du
financement de la sécurité sociale donc
ce sont des moments très importants où
se décident finalement toute la
politique du pays
alors Jean-Pierre me demande si à
l'occasion du projet de loi de finances
de 2023 les républicains vont demander
une réduction de l'endettement alors la
réalité en la matière se rappelle
cruellement à nous puisque sous la
précédente mandature l'endettement de la
France a augmenté de 700 milliards vous
savez qu'on va bientôt franchir les 3000
milliards de dettes cette dette est là
progressé deux fois plus qu'en Allemagne
qui est souvent le pays que l'on cite en
référence parce que c'est une économie
un pays proche des nôtres et donc
nous avons tendance à nous comparer la
comparaison est cruelle pour pour la
France en 2017 il y a 12 ans nous avions
le même taux d'endettement que que
l'Allemagne et nous avons désormais 50%
de dettes supplémentaires donc vous
voyez que c'est une épée de Damoclès et
c'est une épée de Damoclès qui
pèse sur notre souveraineté c'est une
faute morale vis-à-vis des générations
futures et il faut entamer dès
maintenant la réduction des dépenses je
rappelle que ça n'en prend pas le chemin
puisque sur le budget 2023 nous allons
faire un empereur la France va faire un
empereur de 270 milliards d'euros
que le service de la de des intérêts de
la dette approchent le budget de
l'Éducation nationale on va bientôt être
à 60 milliards donc on voit que la
situation est intenable et il faut de
toute urgence effectivement réduire
l'endettement de la France mais
malheureusement ça n'est pas la
politique qu'en tant mener le
gouvernement et le président de la
République
êtes-vous en faveur de la réduction des
dépenses publiques si oui comment la
réaliser alors bien sûr cette question
suit la précédente si nous voulons
réduire l'endettement il y a 47
milliards de dépenses publiques
supplémentaires cette année donc on n'a
pas à cet argent il faut l'emprunter
c'est de la dette supplémentaire
la dette de 270 milliards d'euros dont
je vous parlais elle est faite pour
financer le déficit budgétaire de l'État
qui est plus de 150 milliards et il est
fait aussi pour rembourser les les
emprunts qui arrivent à terme et que la
France ne peut pas rembourser et donc
obligé de réemprunter pour rembourser
des emprunts qui arrivent des échéances
et les emprunts qu'elle va rembourser
ont été contractés à 1% et ce que l'on
fait maintenant sont à deux et demi pour
cent donc vous voyez le cycle infernal
dans lequel la France est rentrée alors
comment réduire les dépenses publiques
c'est difficile c'est vrai c'est
difficile c'est difficile pour tous les
gouvernements et nous avons un certain
nombre d'idées précises la première
c'est d'abord d'instaurer une forme de
sobriété bureaucratique on parle
beaucoup de se briété énergétique mais
il y a une autre sobriété qu'il faudrait
être instaurer c'est celle d'une
bureaucratie qui est devenue
complètement
abondante
vous savez Emmanuel Macron lui-même
disait de l'État français qu'il était
obèse et malvoyant donc il a fait le
constat comme souvent mais il n'en a pas
tiré les conclusions et c'est tout à
fait regrettable donc ce briété
bureaucratif dont on espère beaucoup
réduction des normes parce que les
normes ça crée de la bureaucratie ça
crée du contrôle ça crée de la lourdeur
administrative et cette lourdeur
administrative cette complexité
administrative il faut il faut
l'administrer et ça coûte très cher donc
il faut réformer notre système de
retraite qui est très très coûteux et
qui met en péril le système de retraite
par répartition ce qui est quand même
une des fierté de la France
il faut lutter un placablement contre
les fautes les fraudes fiscales et
sociales notamment par la carte Vitale
biométrique j'y reviendrai et puis sans
doute faut-il conditionner
l'accès des étrangers aux prestations
sociales elles ne peuvent ça ne peut pas
être à guichet ouvert on ne peut pas
continuer ainsi
alors la question suivante est celle
d'Arnaud quelles sont vos mesures pour
faire face à l'inflation alors c'est une
question compliquée la France a pu
maintenir l'inflation à un taux
inférieur au pays européens
essentiellement en finançant l'énergie
les dépenses énergétiques des Français
le bouclier tarifaire l'échec énergie la
limitation du coût des carburants grâce
en particulier aux républicains parce
que nous considérons que il faut
encourager ceux qui travaillent qui
prennent leur voiture pour aller
travailler et c'est pour ça que nous
avons fait voter des mesures qui
encouragent le travail une politique de
pouvoir d'achat par le travail la
monétisation des RTT une vraie
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires donc
l'inflation
elle est produite avec le contexte que
nous connaissons mais l'Ukraine n'est
pas le seul le seul responsable cette
fuite en avant budgétaire que nous
connaissons le laxisme budgétaire finit
toujours par de l'inflation puisque une
dette qui augmente nécessite une masse
monétaire plus importante qui conduit à
l'inflation alors elle est contenue pour
l'instant un peu artificiellement en
France mais au prix au prix de la dette
donc ça n'est ce ne sont pas des bonnes
de bonnes solutions et puis il y a le
système
qui qui
conduit aussi à l'inflation c'est à dire
l'augmentation des prix induit
l'augmentation des salaires qui induit
l'augmentation des prix donc il y a un
mauvais système qui se met en route et
qui conduit à l'inflation
Jean-Baptiste allez-vous demander la
diminution du nombre de fonctionnaires
alors vous le savez
coût de la fonction publique qu'elle
soit d'État qu'elles soient
hospitalière ou territoriales évidemment
pèse sur le budget de la France je
rappelle que
Emmanuel Macron avait promis une
diminution du nombre de fonctionnaires
et qu'en réalité sous le précédent
quinquennat depuis 2017 le nombre de
fonctionnaires d'État a augmenté de 70
000 donc il faut une fonction publique
rénovée mieux rémunéré et moins
nombreuses mais il nous faut une
fonction publique qui fonctionne on en a
besoin dans nos hôpitaux on en a besoin
dans la justice
et sans doute la proposition que nous
faisons et de diminuer l'emploi public
dans les administrations centrales dans
les trop nombreuses agences de l'État
le coût des opérateurs de l'État vous
savez toutes ces agences qui sont
parapubliques en quelque sorte c'est 53
milliards d'euros donc vous voyez que
c'est tout à fait considérable et le
nombre d'agences d'organismes Commission
à vocation consultative ou délibérative
c'est un état obèse un état obèse et
malvoyant comme le disait Emmanuel
Macron il en fait le constat mais il
n'en a pas tiré les conclusions
voulez-vous réformer les retraites avant
de demander de nouveaux efforts ou
salariés de privés ne serait-il pas
judicieux et juste de demander un effort
aux fonctionnaires et aux bénéficiaires
des régimes spéciaux alors c'est l'autre
sujet d'actualité naturellement la
réforme des retraites
je crois que le préalable a tout effort
demandé aux Français et clair il faut de
la justice le système de retraite
français est aujourd'hui opaque un juste
vous évoquez les retraites dans le privé
qui sont calculés vous le savez sur les
six derniers mois quand dans le privé
elles sont calculées en fonction des 25
meilleures années d'activités donc il y
a là une distorsion une injustice et il
existe aussi une quinzaine de régimes
spéciaux qui sont pas la même chose que
les régimes autonomes qui eux sont
équilibrés mais des régimes spéciaux qui
sont toujours financés par le
contribuable donc
réformer les retraites oui on sait que
si on veut sauver le régime par
répartition le
il faut il faudra réformer les retraites
tous les présidents de la République de
quelques
appartenance politique qu'il soit ou
qu'ils aient été ont réformé les
retraites
l'augmentation de la vie qui est
heureuse la durée de la vie qui est
évidemment une très bonne chose
la diminution du nombre d'actifs par
rapport au nombre de retraités implique
nécessairement une réforme des retraites
vous savez il y a trois paramètres le
montant des pensions les pensions sont
faibles pour beaucoup de Français le
montant des cotisations on sait que les
prélèvements sont déjà nous sommes
champions du monde des prélèvements
ou
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
donc c'est un de ces trois paramètres
qu'il faudra bouger nécessairement mais
pour que la réforme soit acceptable il
faut qu'elle soit juste
et qu'elle puisse prendre en compte les
petites retraites les carrières hachées
les carrières pénibles voilà donc c'est
ça une réforme juste c'est la prise en
compte de tout cela mais pour pouvoir
financer tout cela il faut réformer
naturellement l'ensemble du système
alors Paulette comment comptez-vous
lutter contre la fraude sociale et la
fraude fiscale
alors
un mot sur la fraude sociale
le Sénat a voté au début de l'été
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finance rectificatif un amendement de 20
millions d'euros pour lancer la mise en
carte la mise en place le lancement
d'une carte Vitale biométrique pour
lutter contre la fraude desactivés
toutes les cartes vitales surnéraires
donc il faut une carte vitale à viable
on sait aujourd'hui qu'il y a des
fraudes dans tous les sens il faut
renforcer les sanctions de ceux qui
fraudent parce que ça met en péril tout
le système
et il faut traquer par exemple les
retraités fantômes à l'étranger
donc il faut une politique résolue et
ferme de lutte contre les fraudes
sociales
les fraudes fiscales on sait que l'État
s'y est attaqué mais les fraudes
sociales c'est un gouffre qu'il nous
faut absolument réduire c'est une
question là aussi de justice entre ceux
qui cotisent qui ont cotisé pour avoir
une couverture sociale digne de ce nom
et ceux qui en abusent
alors ensuite nous avons Annie quelle
est la position de votre mouvement sur
l'ISF
alors il faut savoir que
c'est un impôt qui a été supprimé ou du
moins modifié par Emmanuel Macron et
nous avons nous l'avons voté nous
l'avons voté parce que
cette impôts finalement plus à la nation
qu'il ne rapportait
puisqu'il cousait un exil fiscal et
fragiliser nos entreprises familiales et
mais nous avons été choqués que dans le
même temps le gouvernement augmente la
CSG pour les retraités par exemple donc
là encore
ce qu'il faut bien considérer c'est que
en fait il faut réduire les prélèvements
obligatoires pour tous la justice elle
est là l'État est un ogre vorace qui en
demande toujours plus donc
comme je le disais nous avons le record
du monde des prélèvements obligatoires
il n'est pas possible que nous
consacrions
que bientôt 60% de la richesse nationale
à la sphère publique pour ça il faut
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent et beaucoup
beaucoup de prélèvements de toutes
sortes
Henri pensez-vous qu'il faudrait
réformer l'impôt sur le revenu pour le
rendre plus universel alors
on peut déjà un impôt sur le revenu
d'une certaine façon c'est la CSG
aujourd'hui nous nous avons une position
que il ne faut pas un euro d'impôt
supplémentaire ni pour les ménages ni
pour les entreprises nous avons nous
sommes le le
premier ou le deuxième pays des 27 de
l'Union européenne avec le Danemark donc
nous avons les prélèvements obligatoires
parmi les plus élevés du monde par
conséquent
il faut il faut mettre un frein à cela
alors j'entends bien certains disent il
faudrait dès le premier euro pouvoir
prélever de l'impôt sur le revenu c'est
compliqué pour les parties les plus
fragiles de notre société mais en
réalité il paye aussi il paye sous une
forme ou sous une autre il y a des tas
de prélèvements obligatoires qui sont
aujourd'hui payés par tous alors
un deuxième
volet concerne l'énergie comment faire
pour que la France défende ses intérêts
dans le domaine énergétique c'est
l'autre question d'actualité je vous
remercie de poser ces questions qui sont
vraiment extrêmement importantes et ça
ça concerne absolument tous les français
puisque la facture énergétique a explosé
alors il est trop facile de dire c'est
l'Ukraine c'est le conflit Russo
ukrainien c'est le tarissement de du gaz
russe qui explique la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes en réalité
la France depuis
Pompidou a travaillé à sa souveraineté
énergétique par la filière nucléaire
c'était une des fiertés de la France
nous étions quasiment au taux suffisant
et à l'arrivée de
François Hollande et même et même avant
sous François Mitterrand et bien il y a
eu une diabolisation du nucléaire et on
a
déraisonnablement fragilisé notre
filière nucléaire et le coup de grâce a
été porté par Emmanuel Macron qui au
début de son premier quinquennat en 2017
annoncé que la part du nucléaire ne
devait pas excéder
50%. et qu'il fallait fermer des
centrales nucléaires il a amorcé le
mouvement avec la fermeture de
Fessenheim dont les spécialistes disent
que sa mise aux normes pouvait lui
permettre de durer encore 30 ans c'est
vraiment un gâchis épouvantable et dans
la loi aujourd'hui existe toujours la
perspective de la fermeture de plus
d'une dizaine de centrales nucléaires
ajouter à cela que la moitié de nos
centrales en exercice
sont à l'arrêt pour des questions
maintenant on est aujourd'hui
extrêmement affaibli alors évidemment
le gouvernement veut développer les
énergies renouvelables il en faut bien
sûr le soleil l'hydroélectricité
il y a un sujet éolien vous le savez
puisque l'acceptabilité sociale de
l'éolien est de moins en moins forte et
même pour l'éolien offshore celui qui
est en mer en réalité on nous le
promettait à l'horizon il est très
visible des côtes et là la beauté la
beauté de nos paysages français
s'en trouve altéré
moi je vois sur le territoire dont je
suis l'élu chaque fois qu'il y a un
projet d'éolienne de parc éolien ça
divise énormément la population
il y a des gens qui ont acquis des
propriétés qui s'en trouvent
dévalorisées donc il y a un sujet
d'acceptabilité sociale de l'éolienne et
je crois que il faut impérativement que
nous nous puissions remettre en état le
plus rapidement possible notre filière
nucléaire et puis construire de nouveau
de nouveaux EPERS c'était une stratégie
de d'excellence la France était leader
sur ce domaine et la gâcher ses talent
et la gâché son industrie et aujourd'hui
à la faveur de cette crise énergétique
européenne nous sommes nous sommes
démunis l'autre point qu'il faut
expliquer on en fera d'ailleurs une
session particulière d'un nouveau projet
que je vais mettre en oeuvre une
rencontre régulière avec avec les
adhérents et tous ceux qui voudront
suivre nos travaux le premier sujet sera
consacré l'énergie il faut savoir
aujourd'hui c'est un sujet technique
mais aujourd'hui on produit de
l'électricité grâce au nucléaire à 50
mow 50 euros le megawette heure 50 euros
le mégawetteur et vous voyez le prix
l'électricité on nous annonce des prix
pour les contrats qui se renégocient à
800 900 000 euros
parce que en réalité le prix de
l'électricité il est
indexé sur le prix du gaz donc l'Espagne
par exemple c'est à découpler le prix du
gaz et de l'électricité pour éviter
cette emballé des cet emballement des
prix mais nous en France il faut
absolument que
nous réfléchissons à cela parce que les
particuliers les entreprises ne pourront
pas faire face alors le gouvernement a
mis en place des chèques des boucliers
des aides mais là encore tout ça se fait
évidemment sur
au prix d'un endettement toujours plus
important et je vous renvoie aux
premières questions
êtes-vous Allah me demande si nous
sommes favorables au développement de la
quatrième génération du nucléaire oui
bien sûr
bien sûr nous y sommes favorables c'est
l'avenir mais là encore Emmanuel Macron
porte une lourde responsabilité puisque
le projet Astrid a été abandonné en 2019
et c'est ce projet Astrid qui devait
nous conduire
ou au développement de la 4e génération
du nucléaire
Jean-Louis Jean-Louis me demande
pouvez-vous
pouvez faire évoluer la réglementation
sur la distance minimum entre une
habitation et une éolienne qui est fixée
à 500 mètres on a déposé des dizaines et
des dizaines d'amendements dans les
différents textes de loi pour obtenir en
effet que l'on éloigne les éoliennes des
habitations et malheureusement le
gouvernement a été totalement sourd à
nos demandes mais nous l'avons demandé
nous l'avons demandé en fixant toutes
sortes d'éloignements plusieurs
éloignements plusieurs kilomètres
un kilomètre et le gouvernement n'a
jamais rien voulu entendre en la matière
nous ce que nous proposons c'est que
on arrête tout projet qui ne fait pas
l'objet d'un consensus local on arrête
de subventionner l'éolien qui est
extrêmement coûteux et vous le savez
l'éolien n'est pas la solution pour
réduire les besoins les pics de
consommation pas plus que cela
pas plus que le soleil
puisque là on a besoin d'énergie de
façon massive c'est au moment
où tout le monde rentre chez soi la le
soir là où il y a plus de solaire et
puis l'éolien c'est très aléatoire c'est
une énergie intermittente donc on ne
peut pas compter dessus pour éviter le
blackout et absorber les pics de
consommation donc il faut du consensus
et il faut évidemment restaurer notre
filière nucléaire
alors on passe à une autre série de
questions qui portent sur la sécurité
l'immigration quelle solution
mettez-vous sur la table face à la
délinquance des mineurs alors c'est un
phénomène émergent on le voit tous les
jours dans les actualités les
délinquants sont de plus en plus jeunes
et de plus en plus violents c'est un
fait à tester c'est sidérant ces
sidérant de voir le niveau de violence
de certains jeunes ça interroge aussi
sur l'éducation qu'ils ont reçu ou
qu'ils n'ont pas reçu mais en tout cas
du côté de l'état des pouvoirs publics
des responsables politiques il faut une
politique d'une grande fermeté et
l'excuse de minorité doit être levée
pour tous les mineurs de plus de 16 ans
aujourd'hui l'excuse de minorité
concerne tous les mineurs mais au-delà
de ses ans
il faut lever cette excuse de minorité
il faut durcir la réponse pénale alors
que le gouvernement la affaibli avec le
nouveau code de justice pénale des
mineurs qui a été adopté en 2019 là où
il fallait au contraire durcir on a
affaibli alléger les peines et
à moins de riz les moyens de la justice
des mineurs donc il faut augmenter le
nombre de places en centre éducatif
fermé parce que les mineurs évidemment
on ne peut pas les traiter comme des
majeurs des voyous expérimentés endurci
les mineurs doivent bénéficier d'un
traitement particulier c'est une
question de
je dirais de d'efficacité d'efficacité
de la justice et puis de
d'efficacité humaine tout simplement on
peut pas on peut pas mettre des mineurs
en même temps que des majeurs dangereux
alors la question de Patrice c'est
comment mettre fin à votre figue de
drogue
il faut des peines minimales exemplaires
bien sûr il faut la certitude de la
peine il y a trop de peine qui ne sont
pas exécutés
100.000 100000 peines non exécutés c'est
absolument ravageur en termes d'effets
sur la délinquance quand vous commettez
un acte délictueux et que vous êtes
certain que vous ne serez pas sanctionné
c'est un encouragement à la délinquance
le gouvernement affiche le démantèlement
des points de Deal monsieur darmanach
fait beaucoup de communications mais ça
ne saurait remplacer la lutte la lutte
contre les réseaux de trafiquants qui
est autrement plus stratégique et de ce
point de vue là la réforme qui était en
train d'être mise en place de la police
judiciaire qui travaille précisément sur
les démantèlement de ces réseaux mafieux
et qui suscite beaucoup beaucoup de
réprobation de la part des policiers
eux-mêmes interroge parce que
si c'est pour mettre plus de présence
policière sur le terrain
loin dans l'investigation on n'y aura
pas gagné il faut au contraire renforcer
l'efficacité de l'investigation tout
autant que la fermeté et l'effectivité
des sanctions
alors la question suivante est posée par
rolega comment se fait-il que certaines
peines prononcent et lors d'un procès en
pénal ne soit pas exécuté
parce qu'il y a trop d'aménagements de
peine c'est un laxisme auquel il faut
mettre fin le gouvernement a une
politique pénale qui va trop
spontanément vous aménagements de peine
pourquoi parce qu'on manque de place de
prison et comme on peut pas mettre les
les délinquants en prison on aménage
leur peine je vous rappelle que Emmanuel
Macron avait promis 15000 places de
prison un peu plus de 2000 sont sortis
de terre donc le nombre de détenus
écroué et rester à peu près stable alors
que la délinquance la violence
l'insécurité a explosé quel trois
chiffres
les violences contre les dépositaires de
l'autorité publique plus 19%
. les coûts et blessures volontaires
plus
36%. les tentatives de mucides plus
41%. et le nombre de détenus est resté
le même cherchez l'erreur donc là voilà
une des raisons pour lesquelles
nous avons certaines peines qui sont
prononcées mais qui ne sont pas
exécutées ou exécutés de façon
totalement décalée par rapport aux
besoins de sécurité que chacun peut
constater alors Marie-Jo Marie-Jo que
proposez-vous face au squat des
logements alors face au squat des
logements
on envoie le
l'exemple quotidiennement dans la presse
sous la précédente monture à nos
collègues Julien Aubert qui était bon
spécialiste de ces questions avait
déposé une proposition de loi pour créer
une nouvelle un nouveau délit d'abord
pour caractériser le squat qui n'est pas
caractérisé et puis pour créer un délit
et pour donner une plus grande et
efficacité à l'expulsion des squatteurs
le gouvernement n'a pas voulu nous
écouter et il a pris des dispositions
c'est madame wargon qui était à l'époque
ministre du Logement
censé résoudre le problème en donnant
plus de pouvoir ou préfet ça n'a pas
marché si ça avait marché ça serait nous
ne verrions pas des faits divers
fleuries régulièrement
à la télévision et dans les journaux
donc
le squat c'est du vol
c'est purement et simplement du vol du
vol de domicile du vol des propriétés et
aujourd'hui on doit évidemment durcir le
droit on doit créer un nouveau délit on
doit expulser rapidement
c'est incroyable que des squatteurs et
plus de droits que les propriétaires et
qu'on ne puisse pas les expulser et là
quelque chose qui qui fait offense au
bon sens et à la justice
que propose les républicains pour
lutter contre l'immigration de masse
c'est la question d'USA
vous avez raison
USA de parler d'immigration de masse
les bons spécialistes de cette question
évaluent à 2 millions d’étrangers
supplémentaires
arrivés en France sous le premier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
alors là où il faudrait prendre des
mesures résolues ferme
Emmanuel Macron et sa première ministre
ont annoncé qu'il aurait une loi mais
qui aurait déjà un débat les débats
on en a
eu suffisamment ce qui faut maintenant
ce sont des actes les paroles on en a eu
beaucoup aussi et les actes n'ont pas
suivi la loizy l'immigration qui avait
été discutée
il y a quelques années
initiative de Gérard Collomb qui était à
l'époque Premier ministre de l'Intérieur
de d'Emmanuel Macron on est ressorti de
cette loi plus exposée qu'on y était
entrées donc il est temps de mettre fin
à cette politique jamais on a autant
délivré de titres de séjour que sous
Emmanuel Macron et je ne parle pas
de l'immigration irrégulière je le tiens
des préfets on expulse 10%
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
dans notre pays
10%, ça veut dire que quand il en arrive
10 neuf resteront dans notre pays ce
sont souvent des pauvres gens des
pauvres gens qui ont parfois affronté
des conditions épouvanta pour venir dans
notre pays qui est un des plus généreux
du monde d'ailleurs
ils viennent directement en France et
cette générosité
elle est un appel d'air évidemment et
donc
il faut mettre fin tout ça nourrit les
réseaux mafieux de passeurs et se
nourrit de la de la misère humaine donc
il faut il faut une politique de fermeté
qui tarisse le flux et il faut faire
mettre une pression maximale sur les
pays d'origine pour qu'ils reprennent
leur ressortissants
Gérard que pensez-vous de la proposition
du Président de la République
d'accueillir de nouveaux immigrés dans
nos villages pour les repeupler
alors je pense que cette déclaration
d'Emmanuel Macron est absolument
scandaleuse d'abord il y a une forme de
vision datée misérabiliste de la de la
ruralité et des villages parce que dans
beaucoup de villages on vit on vit bien
et c'est pas le désert que semble
supposer la proposition d'Emmanuel
Macron ensuite c'est cette proposition
est fondée sur une méconnaissance totale
de la réalité de l'immigration nous ce
que nous voulons c'est réduire
strictement l'immigration qui saturent
aujourd'hui nos capacités d'intégration
nos capacités de logement nos capacités
budgétaires et et la question n'est pas
la répartition la question est le
tarissement du flux et puis je voudrais
dire que si Emmanuel Macron voulait
faire grimper en flèche le rassemblement
national il ne s'y prendrait pas
autrement
pour toutes ces raisons c'est une
proposition que nous pouvons accepter
Christine
Christine demande quelle est la ma
position ou celle des républicains plus
précisément sur l'euthanasie et le
suicide assisté c'est une question
qui qui grandit dans l'opinion publique
qui grandit dans l'opinion publique
parce que
chacun se projette finalement dans cette
question chacun se voit dépendant
affaiblie ayant perdu ses capacités ne
voulant pas infliger à sa famille le
poids de de la perte de l'autonomie et
pense que le thanazisme suicide assister
est une est une solution
c'est une question extrêmement difficile
qui interroge
la conception que nous nous faisons de
la dignité humaine je crois que
personne quel que soit son état de santé
dépendance ne perd sa dignité l'être
humain ne perd jamais cette dignité donc
c'est faux de dire que me semble-t-il
que un être humain perd sa dignité
la deuxième
c'est une question sensible aussi parce
que c'est interroge des convictions
philosophiques pour certains des
convictions religieuses et qu'on peut
pas traiter comme ça
d'un revers en disant bah oui quand on
est plus apte à être autonome bien il
faut autoriser à donner un médecin à
donner la mort vous savez que pour les
médecins c'est aussi une interrogation
profonde parce que c'est un contrario de
tout ce pourquoi ils sont ils sont
formés donc
moi je ne vous répondrai pas par oui ou
non bien sûr parce que c'est une
question trop complexe je vois
d'ailleurs que le Comité consultatif
national d'éthique a donné une un avis
très nuancée il a pas dit non mais il a
émis énormément de conditions pour pour
aller vers cette autorisation ce qui est
sûr c'est que la loi cléonétique qui
traite cette question de la fin de vie
pour soulager la souffrance et la
douleur la la
soulager oui pour soulager la souffrance
c'est une loi qui n'est pas encore
totalement appliquée et partout appliqué
et que s'il y a un constat qu'on peut
faire c'est que en France nous manquons
de services de soins palliatifs ce que
les soins palliatifs sont faits pour ça
sont faits pour soulager la souffrance
et et par exemple conduire à la sédation
profonde qui est un des principes de la
loi cléonetti mais je pense que c'est
une question sur laquelle
nous reviendrons nous reviendrons
certainement
alors
des questions d'actualité
internationales soutenez vous le combat
des femmes iraniennes oh oui combien oui
ce combat est magnifique j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire
publiquement il nous voit ces femmes
iraniennes qui se battent au prix de
leur vie pour leur liberté
[Musique]
suscite à la fois notre nutriments
s'admiration et déchire le coeur aussi
parce que certaines d'entre elles l'ont
payé de leur vie dans des conditions
affreuses et je souhaite que la révolte
des femmes et des hommes diront plus
aboutir à la destitution du des
dirigeants d'Iran qui sont qui sont des
meurtriers qui sont coupables de ce qui
se passe en Iran et la chanson que
chante les Iraniennes bella ciao et
anime magnifique à leur liberté leur SL
femme vie liberté et voilà résume en
trois mots le sens de leur combat et au
moment où des femmes meurent parce
qu'elles veulent s'affranchir de la
tutelle de l'islam radical de
l'islamisme et qu'elle brûle leur voix
nous le voyons prospérer dans notre pays
le pays du féminisme
des droits des femmes c'est tragique
c'est tragique et c'est un sujet que
nous devons traiter aussi chez nous
Jean-Luc comment qualifieriez-vous
l'opposition que vous incarnez basse une
opposition d'abord c'est une opposition
je tiens à le redire parce que
quelquefois on lui dit ah mais vous vous
votez des textes de la majorité donc
vous êtes pro Macron non
on veut que les textes quand ils sont
utiles aux Français c'est tous c'est
notre boussole quand ils sont utiles au
pays nous sommes une opposition s'il y a
plus d'opposition dans un pays il y a
plus de démocratie donc il faut du débat
contradictoire et ce débat
contradictoire on veut pas le laisser
uniquement ou rassemblement national ou
à la nuque nous voulons l'incarner nous
voulons l'occuper ce créneau là du débat
démocratique et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes d'abord une force
d'opposition nous sommes aussi une force
de pression
nous avons mis la pression sur le
gouvernement en juillet pour lui faire
voter des dispositions que nous avons
fait adopter sur le pouvoir d'achat par
le travail et puis nous sommes une force
de proposition parce que nous avons
proposé énormément de choses et plus le
gouvernement entendra nos propositions
quand nous les jugeons et qui parce que
nous les jugeons utiles aux Français et
bien mieux nous pourrons nous réjouir
à quand une union de la droite et du
rassemblement national pour enfin
revenir au pouvoir alors là vous posez
vous poser une question évidemment
tout à fait importante
et ça croise d'ailleurs la question de
Daniel que pensez-vous de l'arrivée au
pouvoir de Georges Amélie
je pense que j'ai peut-être
zapper les questions d'actualité cette
question d'actualité internationale sur
Georgienne et Léonie pardon Daniel
d'abord l'arrivée au pouvoir en Italie
Georgia Meloni c'est parce que
problème n'ont pas été réglés pendant
des années et vous savez toute crise
démocratique se nourrit de solutions qui
n'ont pas été apportées au problème et
nous nous ferions bien d'être vigilants
sur ce point quand les solutions sont
pas apportées et bien les Français se
révoltent moi ce que j'ai à dire sur la
rivée de Georgia Meloni c'est que
d'abord le peuple italien est souverain
il s'est prononcé il a choisi sa
dirigeante et de ce point de vue là je
n'ai pas de commentaire à faire
mais partout
et on revient à la question de Jeanne
sur l'Union de la Droite et du
rassemblement national partout où on a
fait l'union des droites la droite
traditionnelle
républicaine classique si j'ose dire
la droite que nous incarnons une droite
qui sait être moderne qui sait être
force de proposition qui s'est souvenir
à tous qui sait être ferme quand il le
faut mais généreuse aussi mais cette
droite là elle a disparu où elle s'est
tellement affaiblie qu'elle n'est plus
audible
parce qu'en réalité ce que veut le
rassemblement national c'est la
disparition des républicains en cela
d'ailleurs il partage ce combat avec
Emmanuel Macron qui a toujours voulu ses
substituer donc non l'Union des droites
c'est l'affaiblissement c'est la
disparition de la droite du champ
politique donc il vaut mieux travailler
à reconstituer nos forces alors ce qui
ne veut pas dire qu'il faut pas parler à
l'électorat du rassemblement national
bien sûr faut lui parler bien sûr il
était chez nous avant et bien sûr nous
voulons le faire revenir
comment faire entendre notre voix alors
que les extrêmes saturent l'espace
médiatique avec des propositions
démagogiques c'est la question du beurre
Hubert vous posez une question qui est
qui est très bonne mais qui est très
difficile
on entendra toujours plus plus celui qui
hurle que celui qui parle la voix
normale
et donc quand on fait quand le
rassemblement national ou la nuque font
des propositions très démagogiques je
vais vous en citer deux la retraite à 60
ans
proposition des magiques on voit la une
ou le droit à la paresse pour citer une
proposition de la nuque forcément ça
fait le buzz mais est-ce que c'est
raisonnable est-ce que c'est réaliste
est-ce que c'est ça qu'il faut faire
alors
effectivement très souvent on nous dit
on vous entend pas
le sérieux c'est moins audible que
l'outrance et pourtant si nous sédions à
outrance et elle a démagogie nous
perdrions toutes chances de revenir un
jour aux affaires et nous perdrions
toute forme de crédibilité donc j'allais
vous dire Hubert écoutez nous
écouter quand nous parlons écoutez quand
nous nous exprimons
Anne France comment réagissez-vous après
le lancement de nous France par Xavier
Bertrand c'est une question qui a été
beaucoup posée je ne me dérobe pas à
cette question d'abord je voudrais vous
dire que Xavier Bertrand
appartient au République il est membre
des républicains il n'en est pas parti
donc il est resté membre des
républicains et qu'au républicain nous
avons ce qu'on appelle les mouvements
associés libres de Valérie Pécresse est
un mouvement associé nous France est un
mouvement associé et dans la phase que
nous entamons de reconstruction de notre
famille politique après la défaite à la
présidentielle et bien nous avons besoin
d'enrichir notre corpus idéologique avec
toutes les voies qui voudront bien
se joindre pour
et bien
retrouver le chemin du dialogue avec les
Français mais il y a une condition à
cela une condition impérative et je veux
la rappeler et j'en suis pour le temps
que je serai à la tête du mouvement le
rappeler avec la plus grande fermeté
comme je l'ai fait d'ailleurs au
candidats à la présidence des
républicains
l'exigence absolue c'est l'unité parce
que chaque fois que nous avons brisé
cette unité chaque fois que nous avons
voulu faire cavalier seul nous l'avons
affaibli nous nous sommes affaiblis
collectivement et nous avons échoué donc
voilà c'est la seule
le seul la seule condition si tantôt que
ce soit une condition la seule
recommandation
impérative que je veux faire c'est
chercher toujours toujours les voix de
l'Union
Francis pourquoi ne pas faire l'état des
lieux de ceux qui ne fonctionne pas au
républicains afin d'éviter que les mêmes
causes ne produisent les mêmes effets
vous avez raison Francis je pense que
nous avons
à repenser notre logiciel si nous avons
échoué c'est que nous n'avons pas été
entendu si nous n'avons pas été entendu
c'est que nous il faut tout revoir et
d'ailleurs les candidats la présidence
des républicains n'arrête pas de dire il
faut tout revoir oui il faut tout revoir
d'abord il faut revisiter
notre corpus idéologique s'il n'est pas
entendu parler français c'est que il
faut le repenser le le
changer les mots pour le dire mais pas
seulement les mots il faut parler
autrement français s'il ne nous
entendent plus et puis il faut changer
nos façons de faire nous ne pouvons plus
faire comme avant puisque ces méthodes
n'ont pas mais n'ont pas réussi tout
simplement donc ce sera l'immense
enjeu de la nouvelle président ce sera
l'extraordinaire responsabilité du futur
président de notre mouvement
Théo peut-on gagner la prochaine
élection présidentielle bien sûr c'est
ce à quoi nous nous devons nous atteler
mais avant de parler de la
présidentielle de 2027 on sort d'un
échec terrible
et bien il faut il faut se reconstruire
il faut se reconstituer même si je
trouve parfois injuste les critiques que
les républicains se font à eux-mêmes
nous avons aujourd'hui
entre 60 et 65 000 adhérents nous sommes
le premier parti en nombre d'adhérents
nous avons plus d'une centaine de
fédérations nous sommes le parti le
mieux implanté sur le territoire
national donc ne boudons pas quand même
nos forces elles sont là elles ne
demandent qu'à prospérer mais
il faut pour cela amplifier le mouvement
avec tout ce que je vous ai dit
précédemment
comment le mouvement aborde-t-il les
élections européennes de 2024 serait
tenté de dire une étape après l'autre
nous sortons de la présidentielle des
législatives nous aurons des
sénatoriales à l'automne et nous aurons
les européennes en 2024 mais avant on va
élire à nouveau président on va
retravailler beaucoup ensemble et puis
après nous aborderons l'échéance de 2024
pierre pourquoi aucune femme ne se
présente à la présidence des
républicains voilà une question
intéressante mon cher Pierre alors je
pense que notre partie et c'est une
femme qui le dit je pense que notre
partie a besoin de
davantage de femmes bon elles sont pas
absentes
j'étais la semaine dernière en réunion
avec la Fédération de Paris il y avait
Rachida Dati qui préside le groupe
d'opposition à la mairie de Paris c'est
une femme il y avait la présidente de la
Fédération de Paris Agnès c'est vrai
c'est une femme et il y avait votre
serviteur Annie Genval la présidente du
parti certes par intérim et qui sera
remplacé selon toute probabilité par un
homme puisque il n'y a que des hommes
qui sont candidats alors moi je crois
qu'on a objectivement beaucoup d'efforts
à faire que les femmes conquières
progressivement de postes à haute
responsabilité et que les hommes ont
parfois des réflexes un peu masculins il
faut aussi que les femmes
comment dirais-je pousse le plafond de
verre intérieur elles ont parfois un peu
trop spontanément un sentiment
d'illégitimité il faut qu'elle fasse
preuve d'audace qu'elles osent et puis
il faut que les hommes les considèrent
et que les considèrent comme étant aussi
légitimes que il ne se juge eux-mêmes en
tout cas j'ai travaillerai croyez moi
Arnaud soutiendrez-vous un candidat à la
présence des républicains non parce que
mon rôle me m'astreint à une stricte
neutralité sinon je ne peux pas
piloter le processus électoral donc je
ne soutiendrai pas de candidats je
voudrais bien sûr je choisirai
naturellement mais je ne je n'exprimerai
pas publiquement mon choix
comment parrainer un candidat alors
tu à jour de vos cotisations si vous
utilisez à jour de cotisation au 30 juin
vous pouvez parrainer un candidat vous
pouvez regarder sur le site
des républicains il y a une partie de ce
site qui est dédiée à l'élection à la
présidence de notre mouvement et vous
verrez que vous avez des imprimés de
parrainage des républicains et puis il
se déplace beaucoup en ce moment ils
font campagne parce que la campagne
officielle commencera un peu plus tard
mais la campagne officieuse et elle a
commencé moi j'ai commencé ma campagne
législative bien avant que la campagne
officielle ne commence chaque candidat
peut faire campagne et il va ils vont
sur le terrain vous pouvez aussi les
rencontrer et les parrainer à ce moment
là
jean-François a quand le changement de
nom du parti à la refonte complète du
parti c'est une hypothèse certains
candidats l'ont dit donc mais avant de
changer de nom
il faut évidemment le changement de nom
soit l'étape ultime de changement en
profondeur et je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui qui adviendra
parce que c'est une nécessité le
changement alors est-ce que ça change ça
supposera un changement de nom de partie
changement de lieu en tout cas changer
nos façons de faire et changer notre
corpus idéologique en restant fidèle à
nos fondamentaux naturellement il faut
rester fidèle assez fondamentaux ça sera
le l'enjeu des prochains mois en
conclusion si vous ne deviez en retenir
qu'un quel est le message des
républicains alors je dirais confiance
et audace je vous remercie